ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
นักเรียนทุกๆคนนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะถ้าพบกับ
ผู้หญิง
และครูบาฟ้า
อาจารย์นัดดินเนอร์คลาสค่ะไก่แล้วครูฟ้า
คะวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้วัน
พุธค่ะวันนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพุธที่ 24 ค่ะเย้ 24 เดือนอะไร
เดือนพฤศจิกายนเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเดือนอา
กายนต์เป็นเดือนที่ 11 ค่ะปีพตอะไรคะปี
พ.ศ
2556  4 ปีคศอะไรคะ
2021  5 เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันอังคารที่
23 เดือน
เดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะ
เป็นเดือนที่สิบเอ็ดปีพตต
2564 ปีคศ
2  021
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วัน
ถ้าหากอลิซันพฤหัสที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพฤหัส
ที่ 25
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 11 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ค่ะปีคศ
20219 แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 6 โมง
กี่นาทีคะ
06:27 นาทีเขา
06:27 นาทีตอนชื่อแล้วตอนเช้าใช้รถครู
ฟ้าเวลาตอนเช้าตอนนี้ the  three ฟ้าแปรง
ฟันรึยังคะ
ครูฝาแปลงฟันแปรงฟันจะและเวลาที่เราแปรง
ฟันก็จะมีมีอะไรคะครูฟ้า
แปรงสีฟันค่ะแล้วก็มี
ยาสีฟันอา
เวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟัน
เราก็จะมีแปรงสีฟันยาสีฟัน
ตายแปรงสีฟันครูฟานเนี่ยสีแดงโอ้โห
แปรงสีฟันครูหญิงน่ะ
ตรงนี้เป็นไม้แล้วก็อันนี้ดำใช่ไหมดำ
เนี่ยเป็นไม้ไม่มีสีเนาะ
มึงแล้วก็ขนแปลอ่ะตรงนี้นะคะเป็นสีดำ
แต่ของครูฟ้าเนี่ยแปรงสีฟันครูฟ้าสีแดงสี
แดงค่ะอ๋อ
ครูฟ้าอ่ะเนี่ยแปลงปันใช่ไหมตอนเช้านะตอน
เช้าครูฟ้าแปรงฟันเวลากี่โมงคะ 6 โมง
6 โมง 10 นค่ะอ๋อ
6:10 นอันนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยแปลงฟันครั้งที่
1 แนะ
ใช่นะครั้งที่ 1
6:10 นไอฮะแล้วเงินแล้วก็แปรงฟันหึ
แล้วครั้งที่ 2 ณครั้งที่สองครูฟ้าแปรง
ฟันเวลากี่โมงคะอีกครั้งที่ 2 เนี่ยครู
ฟ้าแปลงปันเวลา
9:00 นค่ะโห
เอาแบบไทยเนาะ
9:00 น
นักเรียนเห็นฟังและ
แล้วมีครั้งที่ 3 ไหมคะ
ไม่มีครั้งที่สามต่อไปนี้ไม่มีครั้งที่ 3
งั้น 1 วันใช่ไหม 1 วันครูฟ้าก็แปลงฟัน
แต่แปรงฟัน
สองครั้ง
สองครั้งจะให้ห่าครูฟ้าแปลงปัน 2 ครั้ง
ครั้งที่ 1 ตอนเช้าครั้งที่ 2 ตอนกลางคืน
แต่
ทำไมตอนกลางคืนครั้งที่ 2
แล้วครูหญิงแปลงฟันไหมคะ
ครูหญิงแปลงฝันค่ะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยแปลงฟันตอนเช้า
กี่โมงคะตอนเช้าครั้งที่ 1 ใช่ไหม
ง่าครั้งที่ 1 เนี่ยครูหญิงแปลงฟันตอนนี้
ก็ยังไม่แปลงฟันใช่มั้ย
แปดโมงครึ่งค่ะครูฟ้า
8:30 นแปรงฟัน
แล้วครั้งที่สองครูหญิงแปลงฟันกี่โมงคะ
ครั้งที่ 2 ผู้หญิงแปรงฟันมี
20:00 นค่ะ
[เพลง]
20:00 นก็แปรงฟันครั้งที่ 2 แล้วครั้ง
ที่ 3 แปรงฟันแมะมีไหมคะไม่มีค่ะไม่มี
ครั้งที่ 3 ทรายครูหญิงก็เหมือนครูฟ้า 1
วัน 1 วันเนี่ยแปลงฟัน 2 ครั้งตอนเช้า
แล้วก็ตอนกลางคืนตอนเช้า
ตื่นนอนแล้วก็แปรงฟัน
ครั้งที่สองแปรงฟันเสร็จแล้วก็นอน
นะ 1 วันแปรงฟัน 2 ครั้งนี้ขอ
ไอแล้วเวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟันใช่ไหมแปรงฟัน
เนี่ย 1 ครั้งอย่างเช่นตอนเช้าครั้งที่ 1
ครูฟ้าแปรงฟันใช้เวลากี่นาทีคะ
ครูฟ้าแปลงปันใช้เวลา 4 นาทีค่ะ
4 นาที
4 นาทีใช่มั้ยแปลงฟันอาก็รอเวลามันแรง
ปั่นๆปั่น 4 นาทีโหเวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟัน
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็จะมีแปรงสีฟัน
แล้วก็ยาสีฟันน็อคแล้วก็แล้วก็ไร
มีเพลงคะ
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าเวลาแปรงฟันครูมาฟังเพลง
ฟังเพลงเพราะว่า
หนึ่งเพลงเนี่ย
เห็นไหมเห็นมัวๆๆโอเค 3 นาทีใช่ไหมคะ
สัตว์คดี 40 วินาทีเพลง
เมื่อกี้ของผู้ฟ้า
สมัครเพลงที่ครูฟ้าเนาะเป็นเพลง
เพลงช้า
ก็คือ 3 นาที 40 วินาที
เวลาครูฟ้าอันนี้ก็นี่ก็จะเป็นครูฟ้าใช่
ไหม
ครูฟ้าป่าวเนี่ยก็มีฟันนะคะมันก็มีแปลง
แล้วก็หูฟ้า
อา
เกาะฟังเพลงใช่มั้ยแรงฟันด้วยฟังเพลงด้วย
ๆอีกว่าจะได้
พอแปรงฟันก็เปิดเพลงใช่มั้ยเปิดเพลงค่ะก็
รอจนจริงๆถึง 3 นาที 42 ฉบับอา
อุ้ยนเสร็จ
เวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟันใช่ไหมครูขาก็จะมี
แปรงสีฟันแล้วก็ยาสีฟันครูฟ้าเนี่ยเวลา
ครูฟ้าบีบยาสีฟันสวัสดี
ออกเหรอคะ
พี่ปผู้หญิงไม่มียาสีฟันเนี่ย
ปีบ
บีบยาสีฟัน
ผู้ชอบกูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบเอายาสีฟัน
หน่อยหรือว่า
ยาสีฟันเยอะๆกู้ไฟล์ชอบยาสีฟันเยอะๆแบบ
นี้ใช่มั้ยยาสีฟันเยอะๆแล้วก็ไม่รับแปรง
ฟันมันก็จะแบบ
มีฟ้อง
นักเรียนนักเรียนบีบยาสีฟันเยอะๆและนัก
เรียนแปลงฟันใส่ค่ะมันก็จะมีฟอง
ฟองฟองปอมๆๆผู้หญิงให้ดูฟ้องมี
เห็นไหมเวลาแปลงก็จะมีฟองฟองซองเพราะว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยมียาสีฟันเยอะๆก็สองเยอะๆนี่
ฟ้า
วันเวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟันทำให้ครูฟ้าก็จะ
มีอยู่แก้ว
ไม่มีแก้วแล้วก็ใส่น้ำล็อคมีน้ำก็
บ้วนปากแล้วก็แปรงฟันใช่ไหมๆหามีน้ำ
น้ำเอาไว้บ้วนปาก
แล้วค่อยแปรงฟันถูกต้อง
แล้วเวลาครูฟ้าแปรงฟันใช่มั้ยแปรงฟัน
เนี่ยมันก็มีฟันเนาะ
ฟันบนแต่ก็
ฟันล่าง
เวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟันครู Fast เนี่ยนแปลง
แบบไหนคะโอเค
มีนะเอแต่สมัยนี้เป็นฝัน
มีฟันของเราเนาะปั่น
ครูฟ้าเรียบแรงแบบขึ้น
ลง
ขึ้นลงขึ้นลงขึ้นลงอันนี้เอหรือว่าบีอัน
นี้เป็นปากหรอแล้วก็มีฟัน
แต่ครูฟ้าได้แปลงแบบซ้ายขวา
ซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาหรือว่า c
a  +  b
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยปกติเวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟันครู
ฟ้าแปลงแบบไหนคะขึ้นลงซ้ายขวาหรือว่าทั้ง
2 อย่าง
ทั้ง 2 อย่างค่ะ 4 สี่ก็คือขึ้นลงดีขึ้น
ลงแล้วก็ซ้ายขวาซ้ายขวาไทยหารู้จะ
ขึ้นลงขึ้นลงขึ้นลง
ไฟฟ้าหลักไฟฟ้าแปลงปันนานเนาะ
หวาน 4 นาทีสมัยเวลาที่ภูฟ้าแปลงป่ะเนี่ย
มันประมาณ 4 นาที
มันก็ต้องแปลงขึ้นลงขึ้นลงด้วยแล้วก็ซ้าย
ขวาซ้ายขวาขึ้นลงขึ้นลงขึ้นซ้ายลงขวารี
มิกซ์
ขึ้น
ซ้ายลงขวาเออสวยครูฟ้าก็เลยเป็นแบบ C
สมัยทั้งขึ้นลงแล้วก็ซ้ายขวา
เราครูหญิงแปลงฟันแบบไหนคะ A  B  C หรือ C
เสือครูผู้หญิงแปลงฟันแบบ
AV
เวลาที่ครูหญิงแปรงฟันเนี่ยแค่ขึ้นลงขึ้น
ลงขึ้นลงไม่มีซ้ายขวาไม่มี
[เพลง]
แรงคิดแหนะขึ้นลงขึ้นใช่แล้วนักเรียนเหรอ
คะนักเรียนแปลงฟันแบบไหน
ขึ้นลงซ้ายขวาหรือว่าเหมือนครูฟ้า
ทั้ง a แล้วก็บีใช้ทั้งสองอย่าง
ตอนนี้ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกได้นะคะใจแฟน
แบบแบบไหน
แล้วเวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปรงฟันใช้ไฟฟ้าและแปลง
ที่ฝัน
แปรงฟันโครงฟ้าเนี่ยอ่ะก็แปรงลิ้นด้วยไหม
คะอันนี้คือลิ้นในปากของเราเนี่ยที่นี่
ลินครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีแปลงแล้วก็
แปรงลิ้นไหมคะเวลาที่ครูฟ้าแปลงฟานี่
นิดหน่อยค่ะนี่ปล่อยทำไมหน้าหน้าเป็นแบบ
นั้นเวลาแปลงลิ้นใช่มั้ย
แล้วมันจะหรือ
แปลงลิ้นน่ะลิ้น
อ๋อ
ก็คือครูฟ้าเนี่ยจริงๆแล้วครูป๊าแปลงลิ้น
ไม่ได้มันจะ
อ้วก
ก็เลยไม่ชอบแปลงลิ้นตอนท้อ
คุณครูฟ้าใช่ไหมพอครูฟ้าเนี่ยแปลงฟันด้วย
ฟังเพลงด้วยค่ะครบแล้ว
เสร็จ
4 นาทีมันฝากกับควรปากล้างปากแล้วครูฟ้า
เนี่ย
ใช้น้ำยาบ้วนปากด้วยไหมคะแบบนี้
มีไหมครูฟ้ามีน้ำยาบ้วนปากมั้ยมีอะเป็น
ธุระครูฟ้าแปรงฟันใช่มั้ยแปรงฟันเสร็จ
4 นาทีเสร็จแล้วครูฟ้าก็บ้วนปาก
ใช้น้ำยาบ้วนปากด้วยๆน้ำยาบ้วนปากด้วย
ดียักษ์ท่านผู้หญิงใช้น้ำยาบ้วนปากมั้ยคะ
อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะน้ำยาบ้วนปากมากไม่ผู้หญิง
ไม่ใช้เนาะผู้หญิงแปลงฟันแปรงฟันเท่านั้น
โอเคเนาะแล้วครูฟ้า
ใช้อันนี้ไหมคะ
อ้าวแป๊บนึงนะคะนักเรียนเวลาบางคนใช่ไหม
บางคนเนี่ยแปรงฟันเสร็จแล้ว
บ้วนปากเสร็จแล้วใช้บางคนเนี่ยก็จะใช้
ไหมขัดฟัน
นะอันนี้เราเรียกว่าไหมขัดฟัน
ใส่สายๆๆแบบนี้
เค้าจะเอามาที่ฟันแล้วก็ขัดคุณครูฟ้า
ใช้ไหมขัดฟันไหมคะเวลาแปรงฟันเสร็จแล้ว
ไม่ใช้ค่ะไม่ใช้อัดปั่นไงไม่มีไม่มีไหม
ปั่นถ้าหาผู้หญิงล่ะใช้ไหมคะครูหญิงก็ไม่
ใช้ไหมขัดฟันค่ะมายอีกแปลงฟันอย่างเดียว
นกแรงขึ้นลงขึ้นลงขึ้นลงเท่านั้น 1 แรง
แล้วก็ผู้หญิงเนี่ยใช่เวลาแปรงฟันแค่
พร้อม
ครูฟ้าแบบ 4 นาที
แปรงฟันครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดว่า
1 นาที
เบ็งนาทีเสร็จ
ก็เร็วอยู่ล็อคเร็วๆนะก็ไม่รู้ว่านัก
เรียนเนี่ยเวลาที่นักเรียนแปรงสั้น
แรงปันนักเรียนใช้เวลา
เนาะกี่นาทีครูฟ้าเนี่ย 4 นาทีรู้หญิง 1
นาทีเนาะเรียนคอมเม้นบอกได้นะคะว่าแปรง
ฟันกี่นาทีเนาะ
ใจแล้วค่าวีดีโอนี้เราก็เลยต้องไปก่อนนะ
ฮะไอ้แปรงฟันก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกัน
ใหม่วีดีโอนะน้องอายค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
อ่ะ